So back to business.
We're in a really great position here
because we've gone from one dimension to
three dimensions to get something real,
a real Adam.
And if you take that table from last
time that we got from the old time
mathematicians and plug in according
to what you can use together,
you get the exact wave function that's
a solution to the shredding or equation
for the hydrogen atom for,
or a hydrogen,
any Adam that has only one electron.
It can have any nuclear charge you
want, right? So it's the real thing.
People have shown you pictures, which
are some kinds of approximations of this,
but you have the equation,
the actual formula for the,
for the true way function.
And no one has a better one than you have.
That's the real McCoy.
Okay?
And you can check these pictures that
people have drawn to see if there are
realistic grafts or whether or whether
they're just some kind of artist's
impression or somebody who doesn't
know anything's impression.
Maybe he's not even an artist,
right?
So you can actually do these and they're,
they're the,
the many of them are very simple
functions like to the minus are, right.
You could hardly get easier than that.
Okay.
But you can also draw pictures that
look just like what you can see if the
electron had a color to it.
There are done by ray tracing where the
computer pretends it's your eye and sees
how much density it would go through if
it went through this point or that point
or that point along a certain ray from
your eye and puts a color here that's
proportional to how much electron density
and sees it's not the wave function,
it's the square of the wave function,
the electron density,
that adamant of box plots. Okay. So that,
that's what it would really
look like if you could see it.
And if there weren't problems
with wavelength and, and uh,
and photons knocking electrons
to kingdom come and so on,
that's what it would look like right now.
But it'll be colored,
it'll be colored according to the sign.
The wave function has,
it's not the way functions to square the
way functions. So it would be positive,
but it's colored to say the way function
in this region would be positive or in
this region. Negative. And I'll show it
to you in just a second, but first let's,
or a few minutes,
but first let's describe it.
So there's lots of information on the
screen that you get with Adam in a box.
How many of you have tried
it? Okay, all of you should.
Okay.
First you have the Schrodinger equation
that always appears and it's sort of
silly, but if you need the Schrodinger
equation for reference, there it is.
Uh, then up at the top is the particular
function that's being plotted and it's
given as an l and M,
right?
And also the nickname one
s for this particular one,
which is one zero zero for an l and m.
And then there's the formula that
that particular wave function has.
And you know what it is, it's a bunch
of constants, which we can forget,
but it's e to the minus R,
right? He's not using row here.
Notice he uses actual r and puts in
explicitly the Z and the eight zero
a and the twos canceled.
Okay.
And then he says what the energy would
be in units of electron volts and
electron volts.
23.06 times as big as a kilo calorie,
which is what we usually
talk in. Uh, now you can, uh,
you can look at these
pictures and ask a question,
some fairly simple questions like,
where is the electron density highest?
The nucleus is in the center of
this picture. Not surprisingly.
So this is not a hard question.
Where's the electron density
highest in the middle, right?
No big surprise there.
Okay.
How do you know you
take the wave function,
you square it and find out
where it has a maximum and eat.
The minus distance has a maximum.
When the distance is zero,
the values one falls off
from there. Okay. So the,
so you just to find where
the density is highest,
you just square the wave function
and maximize it. Okay. Now,
but here's a slightly different question.
What is the most likely distance?
Okay.
Can you see why that's a
different question than where
you might think the most
likely distances, wherever the density
is highest, but that's not quite true.
Do you see why?
Okay.
Cause what's most, yeah. No, it
doesn't have to do with motion.
Yeah. Lucas, there's almost
no volume in the center.
If you take the dis say say if you talk
about a point right then there's no
volume at all. Okay. But take a little
box and put it in the center or,
or actually a sphere of a certain
radius, a small radius, you know,
0.01 angst from say and put
it in the center. Right.
And see how much density is inside.
Okay.
But then you could look at one OnX drum
out and now you're looking at a little
spherical shell that's
0.01 angst drums thick.
Is everybody clear?
Cause that would,
so there could be different directions
in which you have this electron density,
which is at that particular
distance from the nucleus.
And the further out you go,
the more volume this shell has.
It's always the same thickness.
But as you move out, there's more
stuff in it. You see what I mean?
More volume in it. What's it
proportional to as you increase our,
how does the volume of the shell increase?
How does the surface of the
sphere increase as you go out?
Not No volume is r cubed
goes with our square.
The surface goes with r squared,
right?
So you have to multiply that,
the probability density by r squared
to see at what radius you have the most
stuff.
Is that clear to everyone?
Because you want to count
everything that's at that radius,
not only in that direction, but also
in that direction, that direction,
that direction and so on.
And the sphere gets bigger as you go out.
So you'll notice that what's given in
this plot here in the bottom right is r
squared times the wave functions squared.
Okay?
So that'll tell you what's
the most likely distance.
Okay?
So you have to do surface waiting
by r squared and it's not zero.
It's at the unit that we use
to measure distance in a zero,
which turns out to be a half
an angst from 0.53 [inaudible].
Okay,
now here's the two s orbital right now,
uh,
which they're here.
Withdraw two different shells
of the same thickness, right?
We'll number them one and two
and we're gonna ask the question,
which one has higher density? Is that,
is that light too much for Ya? Cause it,
can you see? Can you see it? Well,
is it better if I do that
or not? Not really. Okay.
Okay. Which Shell has
higher density? One or two?
One clearly. Okay. Now here's
a different question. Uh,
okay. It's shows one which shell
contains more electron density,
more stuff.
Which one has more probability?
It's not obvious because one has
higher density, but two is much bigger.
Okay.
And in fact the,
the two has about three
times the radius of one.
Right? So how much more
volume does that Shell have?
About nine times more volume. Not
of the sphere, but of the shell.
Okay.
So it's about nine times the volume.
So it turns out that actually two has
more stuff and you see that in this plot,
right? The red for two is
bigger than the, than the, uh,
than the green for one,
right?
So depending on what question you ask,
you have to decide whether you have to
weight it by r squared to get the answer
your need. Okay? Now here's another, uh,
way of looking at a wave function.
This happens to be, uh, uh, the, uh,
it's actually a three d wave
function as you see, not from here,
but from here, right? It's three d.
This is the in three dimensions using
that ray tracing the way we talk about,
but you can do,
if you click slice down here,
then you get a slice through it. Okay?
So that's a, you know, a two dimensional,
more like the contour
plots we've been using.
It's just a slice through the three
d thing. So this is a two d, uh,
not a projection,
but an actual slice of it.
And with this slider here,
you can control where the slice is.
It's in the middle there, so it goes
through the nucleus. But if you want,
you can slide it,
slide it down and see what the slice
would be if it were in front of the screen
that you slice this picture.
Everybody got it?
So you can look at different
levels that way if you want to,
or you can pretend you're looking at the
whole thing so it can be near or far.
Uh, okay. Now let's look
at at this, uh, at this,
these two different,
the two d and the three d pictures,
and look at the pattern of nodes,
the shape and the energy
of the three d orbital.
You see here in the,
in the that there are diagonal
nodes in this three d orbital.
Okay,
so that's three d.
Let's look at this one.
Now we still have those two
diagonal nodes. In fact,
it turns out that they're,
that they're,
that it's at the nodes are actually cones.
This is a slice through a cone
right on the top and on the bottom.
Okay? So the nodal surface, bear
in mind that in in one dimension,
a node is a point in two dimensions
and node is align in three dimensions.
A node is a surface,
right?
So we're slicing it and seek
an intersection of the, of
the conical surface here,
but the actual node is a cone.
Okay,
but is that the only node that you
see in that picture on the right? Oh,
hi. Angela says she sees
a circle too, right?
So there are two kinds of nodes
in this orbital. There's both,
uh, a conical node, which
we had in the previous one.
The three d orbital had a conical node.
That's what makes it a d
orbital having a conical node.
But this one also has a spherical node,
which is a circle when we slice it.
Okay?
So this is this higher energy
or lower energy than the,
than the one we looked at before.
How do you know it's higher?
Has more nodes?
Did you ever see a situation before
where you can have two different kinds of
nodes? Here you have
both a certain this, uh,
this section,
both the circle and blinds.
You ever see anything like that before?
Right.
Anyhow, it's higher energy. It's four
D, Not Three D as You said. And it's,
it's like this, right? You have
both circular and diameter nodes,
but this is three dimensional.
So you have both sphere and cone.
So what can you guess what a
five d orbital would look like?
We looked at a three d orbital.
This is a 40 orbital.
How about a five Dr Bill Lucas,
whatever the third layer of notice,
not a third layer of nodes.
It would have how many more nodes?
One more node. And it would
be in the, in the section.
That would be another circle.
Or actually it's another sphere
of a different diameter. Okay,
so you'll see how you,
you can combine cones in this
case or it can be planes too.
You have planes for P
orbitals. You can combine, uh,
uh, spheres with,
with planes or cones.
And there you can combine them in
different ways to get the same energy.
For example,
you can have a sphere and a cone that
has a certain energy that's a four d the
One we're looking at here.
Or You could have two sets of,
of s, forget the sphere,
but have another cone.
Does that remind you of anything
and get the same energy?
Or you can have a plane and a cone,
or you could have a sphere and a plane,
or are you can have a sphere and a cone.
I said that already.
Or are you going to have two spheres?
Or You could have two planes.
All those are two nodes.
Does everybody see what I'm saying?
And they all have the same energy.
Does that remind you of anything?
It's not exactly the same,
but it should remind you of something.
Okay.
That's what Claude Nissan,
I remember you could get
different combinations in
his case of circles and lines
and get the same frequency.
Right?
So that's why the two s and the two p
have the same energy or the three ps.
The three P and three d
have the same energy. Okay.
Uh,
now let's talk about scaling the h.
Like what do we mean by
h? Like it's one electron,
any nuclear charge,
but one electron.
Why incidentally,
do we want it to be one electron?
Zach, uh, that will turn
out to be case, but,
but even if that weren't the case,
there's a good reason to start
with one electron. Yeah. Between,
yeah, it's, it's true
that we don't want, well,
we'll get into big trouble when we get
Coulombe interaction between electrons.
It's absolutely right, but we want
to walk before we try to run right.
Work with three variables,
not six variables,
which you'd have have two electrons or
three n if you had an electron's. Right.
So we want simple
functions at the beginning.
So that's what the h like wave
function is just one electron,
just three variables,
Rho Theta feet or the convenient ones.
Okay. But now we want to see how we scale
it as we changed the nuclear charge.
We already started talking about that
last time when we talked about Roe,
but we're going to talk both about all,
we're going to talk about size also about
electron density and also about energy
and how the energies of these one
electron atoms change as you change the
nuclear charge. Okay. We, this is
what we talked about last time,
that if you make the table up the
formulas in row instead of in r,
then you could use it for any hydrogen
like Adam because the distance scale,
uh, gets, gets multiplied
by the nuclear charge.
That is to say if you have a given row
that's a given size of the function we're
talking about right
given row, then, uh, it,
you have that value at shorter
are if you have a higher z,
right? A tradeoff betweenZ
and r. If you double Z,
you get the same value at half the are,
does that make sense
that as you get z bigger,
the distance is get smaller?
Does that make sense? Why?
Because the elect,
the nucleus pulls the electron in
more and notice that it's linear,
right?
If you double the nuclear charge,
your shrink by a factor of
two in the distance. Okay,
so increasing z shrinks,
the wave function makes are
smaller for the same row.
That is the same height of the wave
function or the same position in the shape
of the wave function.
Because you have to renormalize
if you shrink the wave function.
Okay,
so let's compare hydrogen carbon
plus six and potassium plus 19 right?
So the, the distance scale, we'll
go one, one sixth, one 19th.
So this is what, this is what it looks
like. If a hydrogen atom is that big,
this is how big the carbon
one electron atom is.
And that's how big the
potassium one electron is.
One 19th as as the linear
distance that's in,
that's in hydrogen. Now how much
does the electron density change?
I think that's the next thing. Uh,
yeah, scaling electron density with z.
You can see that just from
what we just talked about,
if you shrink the distance
by a factor of two,
how much do you change?
The density
factor too is the density.
You get twice as high if you
make the distance half as long.
Right?
It's got to be too cute cause your
shrink at this way and this way.
And also this way. So it goes
up with CSI cubed. The density.
That means if you have a hydrogen atom,
the electrons are every witch away, right?
All over.
But if you have even a carbon atom,
six times the nuclear charge
for the same one s orbital,
the density is eight is six cubed as big.
What's six cube? 36 45 to over 200. Right?
So you have 200 times the electron
density for the one s electron in carbon
compared to the one s
electron in hydrogen.
Where does that crop up in
experiment that you have such a,
so much higher electron density for
carbon than you do for hydrogen and other
things are even more so like
potassium. Where does it crop up? Yeah.
Of what,
what experiment
close what? You can do it by calculation
and you'd see much higher density.
That's what we're talking about is theory.
But where do you see it experimentally?
Lucas?
Not Well,
you can do it in a difference,
but if you look at the total
electron density, you don't
see hydrogens, you know,
unless you look work really hard
because the density of electrons,
which is what you're seeing is so
much higher for other atoms. Okay.
So the normalization, uh, it has
to be one. So if you shrink it,
and that's where that comes in.
We talked about that z over a zero to
the three halves that gets squared before
and uh,
so that it's the size squared
is proportional disease
cubed and the density of
the one s electron as you go across
these Adams goes from one to two,
16 to 7,000 potassium
is 7,000 times higher.
Remember that what we saw that in X-ray,
what a very dark Adam that was.
Okay. So it helps x-ray's find
heavier atoms more easily. Uh,
now how about the kinetic energy?
Right?
So Sai is a function of are right,
some kind of function of our,
but,
but it includes a z.
Z times are right because Roe is z.
Times are so now how does
that influence the derivative,
right?
If you have a function to z of are the
derivative of it is z times the function
of z by the derivative of, uh, of uh,
let's, yeah, rob La, uh,
I got that wrong. No, I,
or do I have it right? That's
right. Yeah, I got it right. Okay.
Now how about the second derivative?
It's going to have a z squared in it,
right?
So the curvature is going to be z squared
times what the curvature was before,
but the value of the wave function
is the same at some saint,
the corresponding row. So what's
going to happen to the kinetic energy
if you have a bigger nuclear charge,
what's going to happen to the kinetic
energy at any point and a corresponding
points, right? It's going to be
proportional disease squared.
The curvature divided by the
value of the wave function, right?
So the kinetic energy is going to really
zoom up for a hydrogen like Adam when
you get a heavier Adam, right? So what,
let's summarize what we did so far.
So distance will shrink according dizzy
electron density will go up according to
CSI cubed, and the kinetic
energy will go with z squared.
Okay.
Now how about the potential energy?
How will it change as we,
as we changed the nuclear charge?
Well,
if we change the nuclear charge,
cool ohms law includes the nuclear charge,
right?
So at the same distance,
You'll have z times
that whatever it was for
hydrogen, right? Much,
much higher or indeed lower
potential energy, more negative,
further from zero.
Okay.
But at a fixed that's,
that's so at a fixed distance,
the potential energy will
be proportional to z,
but the distance shrinks,
right?
So if you look at corresponding positions
in the wave function or you look at
the average, uh, potential
energy, it's going to go,
it's going to also be, uh,
take into account that,
that the distance gets smaller
or gets smaller, right?
Cause of the thing got shrunk,
shrunk, and by a factor of z.
So what happens to the
average potential energy?
How is it scale with z?
Maria, you got an idea
and a given distance.
The energy according to cool ohms law
will be multiplied by z cause you've got a
bigger nuclear charge,
but every distance gets
shrunk by a factorZ ,
right? So if you average everything,
what are you going to get?
There are two factors of z that
are increasing or decreasing,
making more favorable that the,
the energy, the potential energy,
you got that two factors.
So what's going to be
z squared? Right? So the
potential energy, well,
what did the kinetic energy go with?
Do you remember how the potential
energies that the health department,
how the kinetic energy scaled
z squared,
how does the potential energy scale?
How about the average potential energy?
If I doubled the nuclear charge,
how much lower is the obvious?
As I increased the charge,
the average energy of electrons is
going to get lower, but for two reasons,
because the nuclear charge is bigger
and because of the electron is twice as
close.
Okay.
So how does it scale the potential energy?
AverageZ squared?
So the kinetic energy
scales with z squared,
the potential energy scales with z
squared. How about the total energy?
This is a hard one. Z squared, right?
Okay. So the potential energy goes
to z squared and the total energy,
here's a big surprise.
It goes with z squared to,
it also happens to be one over n squared,
right?
So the energy gets,
uh,
yeah. So as you go up in, you
get less stable. Right? Now,
our turns out to be about
300 kilocalories per mole.
If you want to really get
what the energies are,
and here is a plot of the energies.
Here's the the the one s two s or two p
three s or three p or three d four s pdf
and so on, right? But
the distance from zero,
the amount of stabilization is
proportional to one over n squared.
And we saw the same thing if we did
in the one dimensional Coolum case,
the energy was also one over n
x squared.
Okay?
Notice it's independent of l and m three
s is the same as three p is the same as
three d does that square with
what you have learned before?
What did you learn before
Lexi?
Did you learn anything about that before?
About the energies of
three s three p three d
no.
Anybody Chai?
Shy.
Yes,
as lower is lower than p is lower than d.
Now how can both of these things be true
that you heard something that was true
and I'm telling you they're all the same.
Aha.
What you heard about was real outcomes,
things that have many electrons.
I'm telling you about.
If the Adam has only one electron,
then s and p and d are the same,
okay.
But it'll be different when you have
many electrons and we'll see why shortly.
Okay? Cause this is one
electron atoms, okay? So we've,
this just summarizes size
goes with one over z.
The electron density is proportional,
dizzy cubed and the energy goes with z
squared. Whether you're talking potential,
kinetic or total energy.
Uh,
okay.
And it's also one over n squared.
Uh,
and the size happens to be
an over Z as well. Okay?
Now here's a really pretty one
and to do this, to see this,
right,
you want to see the real thing.
So notice that this is a two p orbital,
n l m R two,
one, one. Everybody see that?
I want to show you the real
program that does that.
Let me just see if I
can get it bigger here.
Okay, now what I want for the display,
this display is just as if
electrons were all white, okay?
But we want to call them according
to the, to the, uh, color of the,
uh, uh, this is complicated.
Now I've got to get over here.
We want to color them with the
phase, you know, plus minus.
That's three d.
The phase keeps changing.
That has to do with time dependence,
which we're not talking
about. Okay, now that's,
that's a three d orbital. We want to
have what we have before we had to pee,
right? So I'll make this instead of a
three, a two. So there's a two p orbital,
uh, particular two p orbital
two one zero that term,
which one is that? Notice you have
a coordinate system next door there.
And I can rotate this thing.
I can grab it and rotate it.
The coordinate system rotates.
See that? So I can look at it,
end on if I want to or look at it from
the side. Which p orbital is that?
How do you know points
along the z axis? Okay,
now let's look up the,
at another,
another two p orbital because we
can make em one instead of zero.
So the two one zero is two
peasy. Now what's two? One,
one.
Let me look at it this way.
That's time dependence,
right? And that's weird.
And physicists love this sort of thing
because they deal with Adams in isolation
and Adams and isolation
have angular momentum,
things going around. But Adam's,
when they're in molecules,
when they're with other Adams or
in other things that distort it,
like in an electric field,
they don't behave that way.
So use a different way of doing it,
right?
It's not that physicists are right and
chemists are wrong or the chemists are
right and physicists are wrong.
It's if you're dealing with
isolated Adams or you use one thing.
If you're dealing with atoms
interacting with other items,
you should use something else.
And the way you do this,
dealing with something else,
I'll show you here,
you do what's called super position.
That is you add two functions
in order to get a new function.
Okay?
And the two functions I'm going to add
when I click superposition here are two
one,
one and the other one I'm going
to use is to one minus one
and now what's that?
That's the two p orbital. Okay?
Does everybody see what I did?
So I can combine two of the physicists
or bottles to get the chemist to p why
orbital Dean Boucher who
wrote this as a physicist.
So he writes physicists programs,
right?
But we can trick it to be chemistry
by adding two of his together or by
subtracting them.
And when you subtract them,
you have to put an I in imaginary.
So I'm not going to do it right now.
You can do it yourself.
You'll see down here or you can,
you can do the phase and so on.
The phase of Pi makes it imaginary.
I won't do that. Now
we'll go back to the, uh,
did the PowerPoint.
Whoops, what happened here?
I need to shrink it back again
and now do this.
There we go.
Yeah. Here we are. We're back.
They look the same. Okay. Uh,
so superposition of that kind when you
add two functions together to get a new
function for whatever purpose is a
kind of what's called hybrid ization.
Now there are other kinds of hybrids. Have
you heard about hybrid orbitals? Right?
What that is is adding two
orbitals together to get a
new orbital and let's look
about when that would be.
As we said,
this is the physicist to p m equals one
with orbital angular momentum and it has
complex numbers involved and
the chemists to p is that some,
okay,
now multiplying and adding wave functions.
We've already seen a case
where you multiply functions.
Do you remember where we've
seen things be multiplied?
Alison, do you remember? No.
Multiplied which way functions?
Let me tell you one place we already
multiplied was squaring away functioned as
a kind of multiplication. They get
probability, but I want a different one.
The different different variables.
Ah, for separating the
variables, r theta and fee.
We had an ar function to say to function
a fee function and we multiply these
pieces together to get the total
wave function for the electron,
the three dimensional wave functions.
So that's one place you multiply. Okay.
To get a one electron wave function,
which is we call an orbital and orbital
is a one electron wave function.
That's what an orbital is.
Now you can add or,
but alls to create a hybrid orbital.
That's what we just did.
We took,
we took a two physicists,
orbitals added them together
and got a new orbital. Okay.
2:00 PM Two p y plus two peasy is a
hybrid orbital and orbitals one electron
wave function.
What's the function of,
what variables do you put in in order
to get a value out? How many variables?
Sovi three.
What are they?
The position of that electron.
The one electron,
if it's a one electron orbital, you can
write the orbital as many pieces here.
Two pieces,
right?
But it still is a function of
just the position of one electron.
It's not a function of six or 18 or
whatever number of variables. It's just,
uh, it's just a function of, it's
an orbital, a one electron function.
So it's a position of one
electron that you plug in.
Now you can change orientation
of orbitals by hybridization.
Let's look at that.
So here's the two PZ orbital,
I've rotated the coordinate
system. So Z is horizontal. Okay?
And here's the two P why orbital,
which we already made by adding two
physicist orbitals together. Okay.
Now what happens?
And notice that two p y surprise as
pointed along the y axis to Pz was pointed
along the z axis.
What if I add the two together?
Yeah.
What if I add two Pz and two p y? Now
let's go back and look at two Pz a second.
Notice it's red on the left blue on the
right. Say positive numbers on the left.
Negative numbers on the right,
everybody with me because it assigns
numbers to different points in space.
Positive numbers on the left,
negative on the right. Let's say.
Now this one assigns
positive numbers on the top.
Negative numbers on the bottom.
Suppose I add together,
what am I going to get
Andrew?
Ah,
it should.
They should reinforce in the top left
where they're both positive and in the
bottom right where they're both negative,
but in the bottom left and the top right,
they should cancel.
So if we add them together
to make a weighted sum it,
we don't have to add them 50 50, but
we'll start by adding 50 50. Okay.
So if we add them, uh, 50, 50 mixture,
we'll give that just what you said.
Okay.
So we changed the orientation
of the p orbital by,
by adding two,
okay.
Now suppose we didn't use 50%.
Suppose we used another mixture.
Suppose we use 75% right?
Or there's 50% or 25% okay?
So you can get any orientation you want
by mixing within that plane though,
within the, the, uh, y z
plane by adjusting the ratio.
Okay. There's two pui. Now, what
would happen with a two s orbital?
If you put it in an electric field,
you're changing the rules.
You're changing the potential because now
the electron has a, does, doesn't just,
it's energy doesn't depend just
on assistance from the nucleus.
It also depends on where
it is in the field is.
So we're changing the
definition of, of, uh, of, um,
of the potential energy. So it's a
different quantum mechanical problem.
But I don't want you to think
about quantum mechanics.
I just want you to think about what would
happen if you put an electric field on.
What do you think? What
would it move? The Adam? No,
because the Adam is neutral overall
where we'll do a hydrogen atom here.
Yeah, Adam's neutral so it won't
move. But what will happen?
The electrons will move one way and the
nucleus will move the other and if you
preserve the center of mass right,
then the nucleus will hardly move at all.
I'm the electrons will do
most of the moving. Okay,
so you can change the
shape by hybridization.
We can get something that will
work in an electric field.
Describe Adam an electric field by
mixing the ones without electric field.
Now let's look how we do that.
We make an s p n hybrid orbital.
Have you ever seen that?
And as a number,
can you give me an example to sp two or
three SB three R S P or n is one right
or s p zero have you ever seen that?
S P zero is just ass.
This is how much p there is in
it after you square it. That is,
it's a weighted psalm.
This thing you're using,
you've got different values of a and
B and it's weighted, uh, such that,
so when you square it,
you get a squared fraction of two
s squared. That's the distribution.
Two s would have a B squared of
the way P why would be one squared.
But you also get across term to a,
B times two s times two p. Okay?
Now, so n the number you
put in to talk about sp two,
sp three and so on is the square
of be square over a square.
So if you have an hybrid,
it means equal parts of of s and p.
And if you have sp three,
it means three times as
much p as s after squaring.
Okay?
So it's what fraction you have of of
something that looks like two es squared
and two p squared. And then
there's also that part. Okay,
so now let's just look at some
examples here. Suppose n is zero,
then you have just pure ass.
Okay?
Now suppose you put an electric field
that wants to shift the electrons,
it wants to shift. It would push
a positive charge to the right,
but it will push electrons to the left.
Okay,
so let's here we went to
0.02 just a tiny amount of p.
Let's see how it,
here's back to s and there's spo point,
0.02 it shifted the electrons to the left.
What if I go to a higher value
point?
4.0 4.0 6.0 9.11 point 18.2 5.33 so what
I'm doing is turning up a dial to make
the electron electric fields stronger
and the electron is shifting by changing
the hybridisation. Okay, 0.5 uh,
one there's an sp hybrid.
Now what will happen if I keep on
going make an sp two is for example,
what do you think will happen?
Guess it'll keep going to the right,
wrong. Watch this. There's a,
that's the maximum extension is sp.
That's the most you can extend.
Now watch what happens
if I make it bigger.
Sp Two sp three sp four sp nine
s p 24
pure p,
right? Cause both pure s
and pure p are symmetrical.
The 50 50 mixture is the one
that shifts the most of the left.
Okay. Now we're going
to close here, uh, with,
with trying to go beyond
what we've already seen.
What we've seen is one electron
Adams, right? Hydrogen like Adams.
So we find that we can multiply pieces
are theta fee to create this one electron
wave function,
the orbital.
And we can furthermore add these things
to make hybrids that shift things around
in useful ways. We can add orbitals
to make an sp hybrid, for example,
as what would happen in an electric field,
but it's still an orbital.
So it allows adjusting to new situations,
for example,
an electric field while preserving the
virtues of real solutions of the nuclear
potential.
Because you never put on a field as
strong as the field felt by the electron
near a nucleus.
Adding the external field by turning
up your dial is just a small change.
So you want things to look pretty much
like what they looked originally with the
nucleus. Just a little change. And
you can do that by hybridization.
Okay? The big deal is the nuclear
potential at small distances.
Now let's try to go to a two
electron wave function. Okay,
so what is it a function of? What's a
two electron wave function going to be?
A function of how many variables,
right? Six, right? X, Y,
Z for one electron and x,
Y,
Z for the other electron or r theta
fee of electron one and r theta fee of
electron two and they're
on the same nucleus.
So you measure the distances
from the same point,
but they're two different distances. One,
two, electron, one another to electron to,
they couldn't be the same, but they don't
need to be. They can be different. Okay.
Now, wouldn't it be neat?
That's the question mark.
If we could get that by multiplying
two one electron wave functions,
because we have one electron
wave functions cold,
we look in the table and
we've got the exact thing.
If we could take two of those
and multiply them together.
So orbital a four electron one times or,
but it'll be for electron to remember
what these things are. Just numbers.
If you put in some value of,
of position of electron one and some value
of position of electron to this first
thing, we'll give you a number. The
second thing, we'll give you a number.
If you could multiply those two numbers
together and get the number for the
total way function, that
would be really great, right?
Cause then you'd know how to do it. The
question is, can you do that? Remember,
an orbital isn't one
electron wave function.
So can we multiply orbitals in order
to get a many electron wave function?
Okay.
If we could,
and then of course we would square
it to get probability density.
Now it would be a different probability.
In the first case it was probability
of electron B one being here.
Now it's the joint probability of
electron. One is here and electron too.
At the same time is here. That's the
probability when you have six variables.
Okay. Wouldn't that be
great? It's just paradise,
right?
Because if we had many electrons,
we could just multiply all
those orbitals together.
A certain normal for electron one,
another robot of electron to
another one for electron three.
We know how to write those, multiply
them together. We get the thing. Uh,
we find the total energy
is whatever energy electron
one had plus written energy
electron to head. That's great. Uh,
we find the total electron density.
We know how to find the electron
density of each individual electron.
So the total electron density
should be just the, some of,
so if we were interested in the total
electron density at this particular point,
we'd see what the electron density of
electron one is at that point and what the
electron density of electron
to is at that point.
And we'd add them together and that
would give the total electron density at
that point. So the total electron
density is a function of x, y, Z.
It's whatever this is evaluated at Xyz
plus whatever this plus all the others.
Absolutely. Wonderful. Right? And
then you could write things. Uh,
so the whole is the sum of the parts.
Right?
And you could write things like this at
the top that neon has the configuration,
two electrons in one s two electrons in
two s two electrons and two px to Bwi
and right. Things like that.
You've seen things like that.
So those are the orbitals in which
electrons are to describe the Neon Adam.
Right now,
uh,
this is a problem in joint probability,
so it's like tossing two
coins to try to get two heads.
So I don't know if I can do these at the
same time, but I have two quarters here.
I need your back back in your
head. Okay, so I got tails.
When did you get how often?
Half the time that actually,
if I get tails and you get heads,
that's a quarter of the time,
but a quarter of the time you'll
get tails and I'll get heads.
So heads tails is half the time.
How about heads heads?
How often or does I now I'll bet you,
I'll bet you that I can get head
head half the time actually doing the
experiment.
You want to take the bet?
I would advise against it.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Okay,
two tails.
I lose
book two tails I lost again.
But I think you can see that
I've been doing a lot of time.
I'm going to win half the time.
Why? Why was the rule wrong?
Cause they weren't independent,
right? If they're independent,
the probability of both a and B,
that is the probability that a will
be here and at the same time be,
we'll be here is the product
of the probabilities.
But that if you do this,
that's not true anymore, right?
So if you have two electron wave function,
you square it to get the
joint probability, right?
That electron one will be
here and electron two will
be here at the same time.
So is that valid to multiply here I'm
multiplying the individual probabilities
that electron is at a certain position.
Electron B is at another position.
Do I get the joint probability that way?
Under what conditions do I get the
joint probability that way if they're
independent. Now here's the big
question. Are they independent?
Why not positive, cool ohms
law. They repel one another.
There's no way they can be independent.
They repel one another.
So orbitals one electron wave functions
to express many electron wave functions
cannot be right.
Orbitals are a fiction except
for one electron problems,
right? Hydrogen like Adam's find
we've got hydrogen atoms cold.
But if you got more than one electron,
orbitals won't work.
But still we're going to use them.
Right?
And that's what you're going to find
out after the exam. Okay, good. Lockton,
uh, so that doesn't work.
Good luck on the exam.